par baisse un quartier populaire de
Paris au nord de la capitale
descente de police une opération de
lutte contre la petite délinquance une
quinzaine de policiers
ça ressemble à une opération contre des
dealers de drogue
et ça vous cherchez ils vont directement
dans les plantes habituelles
il y a rien dans les sacs
ce sont des paquets de cigarettes
aujourd'hui une grosse partie du travail
des policiers du quartier c'est la
traque du petit trafiquant de cigarettes
[Musique]
un groupe de vendeurs clandestins vient
d'être arrêté sur le boulevard Barbès
direction le poste de police fouille et
vérification d'identité
les opérations contre les vendeurs à la
sauvette sont devenus quasi quotidiennes
les policiers savent qu'ici ils ne
trouvent que du menu fretin rarement
grosse prise
[Musique]
l'homme à la parc averte assis sur le
banc fait partie du groupe des vendeurs
arrêtés sur lui les policiers ont saisi
quelques paquets de cigarettes
algériennes et 450 € sans doute c'est
vendu du jour
15 la contrebande de cigarettes dans la
rue à un avantage pour les petits
vendeurs elle est sans grand risque
l'homme à la parka n'hésite pas à nous
décrire son travail devant les policiers
à l'intérieur même du commissariat
s
où est-ce que vous les obtenez
moi j'achète
[Musique]
on demande des gens qui vont acheter
pour le monde mais c'est des gens c'est
des c'est des gens qui viennent
d'Algérie qui en ramène c'est quoi
de l'Algérie il y a des gens qui
ramènent deux trois quatre Arthur des
cartouches pour récupérer les billets
d'avion pour
récupérer les prix de voyage c'est pour
ça on ramène
dès qu'on parle de quantité plus
importante l'homme se fait plus évasif
au dessus de deux cartouches la menthe
peut devenir plus lourde
[Musique]
sur place il faut faire un commande
et vous attendez et ça peut se faire
aussi
il faut aller où
il y a des gens qui vendent
une demi-heure une heure
ce vendeur à la sauvette paye une simple
amende de 5 euros par paquet c'est le
tarif l'affaire n'ira pas plus loin
l'homme ressort libre
[Musique]
comme ça tous les jours tous les jours
avec la hausse massif des prix en France
depuis février 2003 le tabac est revenu
au centre de l'actualité des voyous au
ministre
buraliste ce sont des gens qui
travaillent souvent durs et non pas être
menacés par des voyous on parle de mafia
de la contrebande on accuse les grandes
marques de cigarettes de complicité
depuis que le gouvernement a décidé de
surtaxer des cigarettes le sujet a pris
des allures de cause nationale
la recrudescence de la contrebande une
vraie politique de lutte contre la
contrebande internationale la
contrebande des cigarettes c'est près
d'un milliard d'euros de taxes qui
chaque année ne rentre pas dans les
quais de l'État
quelques jours plus tard nous sommes
retournés à Barbès sans la police cette
fois en caméra cachée
visiblement il y a beaucoup de monde ici
on trouve des T-shirts et des téléphones
made in China
un peu plus loin entre la rue des
Ilettes et le boulevard Barbès tout se
vend tout s'achète c'est ici qu'on peut
par exemple trouver des téléphones
portables volés
un peu plus loin au pied du métro voilà
le carré des cigarettes 30 mètres de
trottoir une vingtaine de vendeurs
[Applaudissements]
c'est facile et c'est pas cher ça nous
fait le paquet à 3,50 € c'est le prix
unique et donc 1,50 € sur le prix
officiel pour les débutants de tabac la
concurrence est bien là à Barbès ce
petit trafic est la partie émergée d'un
tout autre business
aujourd'hui en Europe la contrebande
s'est organisée autour de véritables
filières internationales avec
transporteur anthropoc clandestins et
financier en costume cravate nous allons
vous emmener dans les rouages de ces
filières qui dégagent des milliards
d'euros de profils illégaux
nous nous sommes rendus à 300 km de
Paris aux frontières nord de la France à
Dunkerque à deux pas de la Belgique et à
une encablure de l'Angleterre le port de
Dunkerque est un carrefour des routes
maritimes et terrestres
chaque année plus de 50 millions de
tonnes de marchandises les plus diverses
il transitent par conteneur ou par
camion entier c'est là qu'on fait les
plus grosses saisies de tabac dans le
pays
dans la région 70 douaniers sont
mobilisés pour la traque de la cigarette
c'est leur priorité leur pain quotidien
ce jour-là sur le quai des hydrocarbures
perquisition d'un pétrolier polonais à
la recherche de caisse de conteneurs
suspects les bateaux et les camions en
provenance des pays de l'Est font
l'objet d'une surveillance particulière
il représente une grande partie des
saisies le capitaine fournit la liste
des ports d'escales c'est la première
chose que les douaniers regardent ils
auscultent à la loupe ce document il
représente l'historique des étapes du
navire ce bateau est suspect il a
multiplié les escales en peu de temps
c'est vrai que ça peut être intéressant
par exemple pour les produits
stupéfiants il y a titre général ça peut
être intéressant pour la vieillement un
navire de commerce peut habiter dans
dans certains ports et donc bénéficier
de de stocks importants par rapport au
nombre de
personnes de l'équipage lavitaillement
c'est l'épicerie et le buraliste hors
taxes du bateau c'est là que l'équipage
se fournit et que les fraudes sont
possibles le règlement douanier n'est
pas très précis il dit la quantité de
cigarettes doit correspondre à une
consommation normale on passe à la
fouille direction la cambuse sous le
troisième pont ici sont stockés les
marchandises déclarés par le capitaine
et des cartons de cigarettes il y en a
pas mal
[Musique]
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 ça fait 400 c'est un
crayon
25 35 37 au total c'est 600 cartouches
ou 120 000 cigarettes pour quelques
jours de mer et 20 membres d'équipage
près de quatre cartouches par jour par
marin c'est quand même pas mal pour un
faible équipage
pour les bateaux
il fait de lui-même quoi en liquide le
citron de l'heure
le douanier a bien envie de sanctionner
mais le volume correspond au document de
déclaration officielle donc difficile de
verbaliser tant que les cigarettes ne
sont pas débarquées pour être revendus
en fraude
le port de Dunkerque est une plaque
tournante pour la contrebande à
destination de toute l'Europe du Nord on
estime aujourd'hui qu'un tiers de la
consommation de cigarettes en Angleterre
ou en Norvège par exemple provient des
filières de contrebande vers la France
le trafic est moins important le
syndicat des buralistes l'estime à
environ 8% de la consommation totale en
augmentation depuis un an
pour le chef douanier de Dunkerque la
seule chose palpable certaines c'est son
tableau de chasse
1125 kg ici 2 tonnes et demi 122000
paquets de cigarettes
4900 cartouches vous voyez ça c'est
c'est les résultats de cette unité ici
pour pour une pour une année il fallait
plutôt moi pour les plus significatifs
qui ont fait l'objet d'un d'une coupure
de presse au total c'est un moyen une
tonne de cigarettes qui sont saisis
chaque semaine dans la région une partie
seulement des cargaisons se retrouve sur
les trottoirs parisiens la destination
numéro 1 c'est Londres c'est à secteur
porteur c'est affluent direction de la
Grande-Bretagne qui est alimenté
régulièrement uniquement la
Grande-Bretagne oui ici je vous dis on
est en transit entre les pays du Benelux
voir les pays de l'Est de l'ancien bloc
de l'Est vers la Grande-Bretagne parce
que il y a un grand différentiel
d'assise de droit indirects sur sur ces
produits là
les trafiquants ont vite fait leur
calcul le prix de la cigarette pour les
trois quarts ce sont des taxes la
différence de prix entre les différents
pays voilà le véritable ressort sur
lequel joue les contrebandiers
l'Angleterre est avec la Norvège le pays
où les taxes sont les plus lourdes donc
le prix de la cigarette il est de loin
le plus élevé c'est d'abord vers ces
pays que se concentre aujourd'hui encore
l'essentiel du trafic illégal comme tout
bon commerçant les contrebandiers pour
se fournir sont à l'affût des régions où
les cigarettes sont les moins chères
parmi ces pays Chypre Malte et le
Monténégro ou le paquet de cigarettes
coûte moins de 2 euros le jeu pour les
trafiquants consiste à acheter les
paquets à bas prix et à les acheminer
illégalement vers les pays du Nord
ils revend alors leur paquet à trois ou
quatre euros sur les marchés parallèles
selon les douanes européennes le
Monténégro et le pivot de cette
contrebande de cigarettes à destination
de l'Europe
c'est un petit pays grand comme une
région française à peine 620 000
habitants face à l'Italie à la porte de
l'Europe communautaire
cette ancienne république yougoslave
fait aujourd'hui partie de la fédération
de Serbie
l'Europe semble loin
coincé entre mer lac et montagne
l'endroit est pauvre
essentiellement rural seule une énorme
usine d'aluminium un vestige de l'air
communiste assure les rares exportations
officielles du pays
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
votre gorille ça c'est la capitale une
petite ville un peu endormie ici la
contrebande est une tradition avec la
guerre en Yougoslavie et les embargos
c'est même devenu la principale activité
économique du pays en plein centre-ville
nous croisons des petits revendeurs un
peu comme à Paris sauf qu'ici il ne se
cache pas
OK
on trouve toutes les marques fumées en
Europe sur ce paquet l'avertissement
fumé peut tuer n'est pas écrit en serbe
la langue du pays mais en anglais
smoking kills des cigarettes visiblement
destinées au marché britannique tombé du
camion
[Musique]
au grand marché de la ville on peut
obtenir sans difficulté des tarifs
encore plus concurrentiels et des
quantités plus importantes
[Musique]
OK
ça va à 15 euros la cartouche c'est deux
fois moins cher qu'à Barbès on peut
facilement acheter une dizaine de
cartouches
nous avons attendu la nuit pour prendre
rendez-vous avec un contrebandier plus
important un semi grossiste rencontré
sur le marché il nous emmène faire un
tour de la ville et préfère rester
anonyme
son instrument de travail à lui c'est sa
voiture son coffre est bourré de
cigarettes
ok
il y en a de toutes sortes
et quel est le prix pour pour un coffre
plein alors le prix de tout ça c'est 700
euros
combien vous gagnez là dessus entre 25
et 30 euros ça représente quoi comme
travail
toute la journée et j'arrête pas
l'homme gagne 30 euros par jour pour un
coffre plein ça peut paraître modeste
mais ici c'est 4 fois le revenu moyen
est-ce que c'est dangereux votre travail
le risque est grand plus j'achète plus
je suis exposé moi les flics m'ont déjà
confisqué mon coffre plein il n'y a eu
aucune convocation on m'a juste
confisqué le coffre
on ne peut pas dire que les policiers
sont égaux parce qu'ils pourraient et
nous envoyer en prison mais ils ne font
que saisir la marchandise pour ceux qui
achètent des camions entiers de
cigarettes c'est autre chose une
remorque ça représente 300 caisses il y
en a pour 150000 euros
ceux qui trafic par dizaines voire
centaines de cartons font la une des
journaux quand ils sont arrêtés fin
janvier en première page du principal
quotidien local s'étaler la photo d'un
camion-citerne dans la neige intercepter
la veille de notre passage par les
douanes le camion se dirigeait vers la
frontière nord cela route qui mène vers
l'Europe de l'Ouest
nous avons demandé à voir le
camion-citerne qui a fait la une de la
presse
il est exposé comme un trophée dans le
parking des douanes le chef douanier en
civil feldide c'est un de ses collègues
qui a réussi à découvrir le stock de
cigarettes et ce n'était pas évident en
matière de cachette l'imagination est au
pouvoir
[Musique]
le conducteur avait un comportement
suspect
d'accord
toute cette partie là ils ont fabriqué
une cloison métallique et là dedans ils
ont planqué les cigarettes trois sortes
de cigarettes en tout il y avait 190
cartons il y en a pour environ 60 000
euros peut-être un peu plus
l'intercepter au poste frontières de la
route de Rosa coula en direction du
Kosovo
les douaniers n'ont pas voulu nous
laisser rencontrer le chauffeur nous
aurions pourtant voulu connaître sa
destination et surtout il pouvait
s'approvisionner nous sommes retournés
voir notre trafiquant nocturne il sait
où ça se passe
ça vient par bateau ce qui travaille en
gros ce qui achètent 50 ou 100 cartons
ce qui achète en grande quantité vont au
port
les petits ne peuvent pas acheter là-bas
les grossistes ne voudraient pas leur
vendre le port dont parle notre
contrebandier c'est bar à 50 km de la
capitale podorite ça de l'autre côté de
la chaîne de montagne au terminus de la
principale route du pays
unique accès maritime pour les gros
navires dans cette zone des Balkans bar
est situé juste en face de l'Italie
c'est le port du Monténégro
la quasi totalité des marchandises du
pays passe par ici
c'est ici aussi que selon notre
trafiquant se ferait l'approvisionnement
en cigarette en grosse quantité sur
place pas le moindre bâtiment marqué
tabac ou cigarettes seulement des
conteneurs anonymes nous demandons un
rendez-vous au directeur du port pour
tenter de confirmer nos informations
surprise il ne cache pas
qu'effectivement il s'y transit de
grosses quantités de cigarettes
avant l'éclatement de la Yougoslavie
notre port à travailler dans la
cigarette pendant les sanctions
aujourd'hui
notre port travaille encore dans la
cigarette
demain il travaillera toujours dans
cigarette mes nouvelles surprises quand
on interroge sur la légalité de ce
commerce l'homme affirme être au courant
de rien que les papiers de douane des
conteneurs soient en règle ou non il ne
veut pas le savoir
ils vont les marchandises qui passent
par ici
au courant
on peut pas mettre quelqu'un en
permanence sur les quais
une solide langue de bois difficile
d'obtenir plus d'informations avec le
directeur du port
direction les douaniers
à l'improviste nous entrons dans leur
bureau à l'autre bout du quai
il faut s'adresser au chef un peu plus
loin
celui-ci accepte de nous recevoir
quelques minutes mais sans caméra nous
lui volons quelques mois l'image il est
à droite de l'écran mais pas de chance
la contrebande sur le port hier comme
aujourd'hui il n'en a jamais vu il vient
d'arriver
et bien écoutez je ne suis là que depuis
deux mois
ce qui fait qu'à propos de ce qui a pu
se passer à Bar je ne veux pas dire de
bêtises
je ne sais pas
troisième tentative avec la police
maritime cette fois
[Musique]
l'officier est très fier de nous montrer
qu'il est bien équipé et que la
situation est sous contrôle
il insiste pour nous faire goûter les
joies de la navigation à bord de sa
belle vedette un vrai bateau de course a
priori s'il y a des contrebandiers ils
n'ont qu'à bien se tenir
un bateau anglais
les propulsés par trois moteurs Volvo
pentaturbo diesel avec compresseur ça
nous fait une puissance de 690 chevaux
au total
pourquoi avez-vous besoin d'un aussi
gros bateau
je savais notre mission prioritaire
pour nos unités
et d'empêcher toute activité illégale
sur cette zone
l'homme est prolixe sur sa mission
officielle et sur son engin
mais dès qu'on évoque avec lui les
filières clandestines du tabac
c'est motus
est-ce qu'il y a des problèmes de
contrebande ici
non ça n'existe pas
les douanes estiment que le trafic
évitant ce port depuis plus de 10 ans
mais toujours pas de chance lui aussi il
est nouveau
avant je n'étais pas là alors je sais
pas
on en apprendra pas beaucoup plus pour
l'instant sur place pas un seul indice
de ce que nous avait raconté notre
trafiquant nocturne pourtant selon les
autorités de douanières européennes bar
et bel et bien un maillon central de la
chaîne de contrebande de cigarettes en
Europe ici transitait selon la justice
italienne 50 millions de cartouches par
an
le port de Bar est un emplacement
stratégique juste en face de Barry en
Italie à la porte de l'Europe
communautaire
c'est là à Bari que nous allons trouver
la première clé pour entrer dans les
rouages de ce trafic
c'est dans ce palais de justice que se
tient le plus grand procès d'un réseau
de trafiquants accusé d'organiser la
contrebande de cigarettes à partir du
Monténégro vers l'Europe communautaire
après des années d'enquêtes les juges
italiens ont réussi à procéder à des
dizaines d'incultations et des centaines
de saisies de compte bancaires
l'audience du jour se déroule dans cette
petite salle
l'homme qui entre en veste jaune c'est
le procureur anti-mafia Giuseppe Chelsea
c'est lui qui a fait tomber le réseau
la cuisine numéro 1 le boss présumé de
ce réseau c'est cet homme en costume et
lunettes il s'appelle Gérard de Comeau
pour la justice italienne il est l'un
des plus gros trafiquants internationaux
de cigarettes dans cette affaire il
risque dix ans de prison
[Musique]
on lui reproche d'être membre d'une
association mafieuse d'avoir financé un
circuit criminel et d'avoir organisé la
contrebande d'armes et de tabac
Gérard de Komo et napolitain il
dirigeait une société d'import-export
domicilié en Suisse la maximesse a il
achetait également des cargaisons de
cigarettes hors taxes à envers en
Belgique où se trouvent les entrepôts
des fabricants américains
ces cigarettes étaient envoyées par
bateau ou camion Monténégro
elles y recevaient un tampon dédouane
monténégrine comme si elles étaient
destinées à la consommation locale sauf
qu'en fait les cigarettes ne faisaient
que transiter au Monténégro et repartait
vers l'Europe communautaire en cachette
sans payer les taxes d'entrée dans les
vrais pays destinataires soit les
cigarettes étaient dissimulées dans des
camions pour rejoindre l'Angleterre ou
les pays nordiques soit elles partaient
par bateau vers l'Italie pour être
réexpédié vers les marchés Nord
européens ces filières sont toujours
actives aujourd'hui
nous nous sommes procurés des films
tournés par les gardes des finances
italien les vedettes offshore sont
celles des contrebandiers quittant à la
nuit tombée le port de bar destination
les côtes italiennes sur ces images on
devine la cargaison parfois jusqu'à 215
de cigarettes pour un seul bateau pour
une valeur d'un million d'euros la
traversée du rappel 3 ou 4 heures à bord
de ses vedettes surpuissantes les
réservoirs d'essence sont remplis en
pleine course pour débarquer au plus
vite la précieuse cargaison
quand les vedettes des contrebandiers se
font prendre en chasse par les navires
des gardes des finances italiens
c'est la course et la bataille des
abordages parfois extrêmement violents
pour s'échapper les trafiquants n'hésite
pas à percuter les navires des douaniers
sur le quai des douanes à Bari en Italie
on compte les cours
et puis résultats
des contrebandiers heureusement il n'y a
pas eu de blessés parce que sur ce type
d'unité le personnel de bord se trouve
sur le pont à l'extérieur de
l'embarcation
cette violence rappelle les attaques de
banque ou de fourgon blindés on est
propre pour passer coûte que coûte
quel que soit l'obstacle
heureusement le militaire dont le poste
se trouvait exactement à l'endroit où il
y a eu la pacte s'est éloigné
suffisamment pour ne pas être touché ou
blessé
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il y a une
escalade des pratiques des
contrebandiers
dès que les caisses de cigarettes
entrées en fraude sur le sol italien
sont débarqués des bateaux elles sont
prises en charge par d'autres équipes de
contrebandiers
là les douaniers ont réussi à filmer de
nuit en caméra thermique d'un
hélicoptère on distingue les camions un
groupe d'hommes transborde les caisses
de cigarettes le convoi se forme
et se met en mouvement à travers la
ville destination Naples et le nord de
l'Europe
tout semble parfaitement organisé minute
sauf lorsque les gardes des finances
croisent leur chemin
pour la justice italienne l'un des
responsables des filières mises en cause
ces Girardot
à l'issue de l'audience du tribunal de
Bari l'homme a accepté de nous recevoir
chez lui en Italie du Nord nous le
retrouvons dans la banlieue chic de
Bologne une propriété de Gentleman
Farmer c'est là qu'il réside il est en
liberté provisoire et doit pointer
chaque jour au commissariat civilité
élégance le trafiquant présumé se fait
très aimable
à 58 ans l'homme a été plusieurs fois
condamné pour contrebande de cigarettes
et trafic de stupéfiant mais ce qui le
chagrine vraiment ce jour-là cet artema
sur ses photos son yacht de luxe un je
joue 30 mètres il était amarré dans le
port de Cannes il a été saisi
[Musique]
à l'heure actuelle ma vedette est sous
séquestre et les saisies dans l'attente
de l'issue du procès mais la France a
été sollicitée
à l'entendre il ne serait qu'un honnête
employé d'une société spécialisée dans
la vente de tabac
mon travail c'était de faire du
commercial auprès de la société Maxime
des cigarettes
des années d'expérience
cette société est régie par le droit
suisse
et sur le registre du commerce il est
écrit comme objet social cigarette
alcool produit de luxe
moi je travaillais exclusivement à
l'export hors taxes
ce n'est pas la vie de la justice
italienne ce qui a intrigué les juges
c'est que sous cette couverture
officielle l'homme en fait n'avait qu'un
seul client en italien installé au
Monténégro et pour des volumes
impressionnants
ça représente environ 30 à 35000 pièces
de cigarettes par mois
sur 12 mois si on fait une moyenne entre
les mois où on fait un plus gros chiffre
et ceux où on fait moins ça représente
au final entre 280 000 et 300000 pièces
par an
un million 500000 cartouches par an à
lui seul à destination du petit
Monténégro avec ses associés gérardot
como aurait pu assurer quatre fois la
consommation annuelle du pays c'est ce
qui a convaincu les juges que la
destination réelle des cigarettes ne
pouvait être ce petit pays balkanique
pour la justice italienne Komo n'avait
en fait pas de clients Monténégro mais
des associés qui réexpédier les
cigarettes en contrebande vers l'Italie
notamment un certain Francesco
Prudentino arrêté en novembre 2000
si ce monsieur a revendu cette
marchandise à une autre personne si
cette personne la chargée sur des
bateaux et transporté en Italie moi
monsieur como est la société Maxime nous
n'y sommes strictement pour rien
ce n'est pas ce que dit la justice
italienne ce n'est pas ce que dit non
plus un homme que nous avons retrouvé en
Suisse il s'appelle Adriano Corti il est
poursuivi dans le même procès que
gérardo como pour association mafieuse
et blanchiment d'argent c'est un ancien
associé de gros mots il collectait en
Italie les fonds de la revente des
cargaisons de tabac par le réseau des
trafiquants aujourd'hui il est fâché
avec gérardo como leur est au règlement
de compte monsieur Gourmont était le
directeur général de la maxime président
de la maxime et donc ils vendait des
cigarettes des clients italiens qui le
contactaient et qui voulait acheter au
Monténégro moi j'ai eu des factures pour
915 c'était le minimum d'une facture qui
est un client acheté chez Maxime 900
caisses 9 tonnes l'équivalent d'un
conteneur plein de cigarettes cette
facture date de 1998 ici c'est plus de
1000 caisses qui ont été livrés un
commerce très rentable
il faudrait calculer qu'est-ce que c'est
le prix de transport qui demande la
personne qui transporte avec le bateau
de contrebande la cigarette depuis le
Monténégro sur les côtes de la police
mais je peux calculer que la maxime
gagne peut-être sur les 20-25 dollars le
carton dans la vente en gros je pense
qu'un bateau changé sur les 220 250
cartons par parfois à ce rythme là le
réseau empochait 600000 dollars par mois
à la fin des années 90 des sommes
colossales qui permettent de s'acheter
toutes les protections et les
complicités la justice italienne la
réalisée assez dépend quand elle a voulu
démonter le réseau Komo au Monténégro
certains de ces associés étaient
protégés par des personnalités haut
placées les mandats d'arrêt lancés par
le procureur de Bari Giuseppe Chelsea
n'aboutissait jamais
à ce stade de l'enquête quand on leur
demandait d'extrader ces personnes il
nous répondait elle ne se trouve pas
chez nous comment expliquer un tel
comportement des autorités du Monténégro
il tient en un chiffre 50% du PNB la
moitié de la richesse nationale c'est ce
que rapporterait le trafic grâce aux
sommes prélevées à l'entrée des
cigarettes dans le pays en échange du
tampon officiel des douanes un tour de
passe-passe qui aujourd'hui encore
profiterait directement à certaines
personnalités du Monténégro septembre
2003 la justice italienne lance un
mandat d'arrêt international contre les
proches du Premier ministre
milojukanovic un document que nous
sommes procurés c'est plus proche d'amis
sont directement mis en cause l'affaire
va faire scandale sur place et leur
vaudra la une du magazine le plus du
pays avec un titre accusateur les hommes
du président
[Musique]
Nébo jamais de yévitch dirige un parti
politique d'opposition au Monténégro
cette mise en cause ne le surprend pas
ce qu'il étonne c'est que son premier
ministre en assume pas les conséquences
en démissionnant
toutes les personnes accusées sont des
amis de jokanovic dans tous les pays du
monde ce serait un problème vous voyez
ici monsieur
qui est allé dans des poches de
personnes privées tout va dans le budget
de l'État sauf que tous les gens qui
organisent ce trafic cours qui sont
appliqués dans ce trafic ou vers une
vente aujourd'hui ce sont les gens les
plus riches du Monténégro il y a quelque
chose de bizarre
chef de fil de série Jamie du Premier
ministre du canovic cité dans le mandat
d'arrêt vezeline barovitch peut-être
l'homme le plus puissant du pays associé
à plusieurs sociétés d'État cet homme
d'affaires est aussi le président du
plus grand club de basket du Monténégro
le boudouchnost sur cette photo on le
voit cigare aux lèvres dans les gradins
à l'occasion d'une rencontre sportive
avec son ami le Premier ministre
depuis le lancement du mandat d'arrêt
international contre lui varevitch s'il
vit toujours comme un ABAB fut les
caméras nous avons cherché à le
rencontrer d'abord dans le plus grand
hôtel de la ville dont il serait le
propriétaire puis dans un restaurant
chic de la capitale où il a ses
habitudes mais pas de chance il refuse
l'obstinément de répondre aux questions
aux autres comme à celle de la justice
internationale
[Musique]
il ne fait pas bon venir semer de ses
affaires
il y a 2 ans un journaliste local a eu
le temps de s'intéresser de trop près à
lui coacha Pavlovic a réalisé un
reportage sur la contrebande de
cigarettes au Monténégro mal lui en a
pris
ça a pris de telles proportions que ça a
été un véritable tremblement de terre
pendant deux jours j'ai reçu près de
1000 appels téléphoniques
[Musique]
de sécurité la police secrète m'a
prévenu que monsieur barovitch avait
chargé certaines personnes de me
soumettre à un interrogatoire
au bout de quelques jours le même ami
m'a prévenu que finalement l'opération
avait été empêché sur l'intervention du
ministre de l'Intérieur de l'époque et
de Monsieur ducanovic après ces mises en
garde le journaliste a été contraint de
démissionner de son poste de rédacteur
en chef à la télévision du Monténégro
la vedette du mandat d'arrêt
international c'est le premier ministre
en personne Millau Djukanovic il n'est
pas poursuivi du fait de son immunité
d'homme d'État mais son nom est bien
cité selon le document d'Interpol il
aurait touché directement de l'argent
sur les opérations de contrebande de
tabac ces sommes étaient effectivement
versées sur les comptes bancaires au nom
de juanovic en lien avec les opérations
de ses amis ces derniers faisaient
partir le chargement de tabac stocké
près des ports du Monténégro vers
l'Italie et les autres pays de l'Europe
l'homme côtoyait y a encore peu de temps
tous les leaders occidentaux de Bill
Clinton à Tony Blair
ou encore Jacques Chirac
[Musique]
en décembre dernier le Premier ministre
a dû répondre publiquement au graves
accusations dont il fait l'objet au
cours d'une interview télévisée sur la
chaîne nationalement tenegrine
[Musique]
pour se justifier le Premier ministre
prend prétexte des sanctions de l'ONU du
temps de la guerre mais la guerre est
terminée depuis 4 ans la plainte elle
porte sur des faits de contrebande
datant de 2003 nous n'avons pas pu
obtenir un rendez-vous avec le Premier
ministre c'est le ministre des Affaires
étrangères qui accepte finalement de
nous répondre et quand on évoque le
mandat d'arrêt international
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour être très honnête avec vous d'un
point de vue politique
ça n'a jamais eu beaucoup d'intérêt ça
fait des années que j'entends ça quand
j'ai entendu que monsieur dukanovic
était impliqué dans le trafic je me suis
mis à rire
honnêtement c'est une histoire
complètement incroyable ça n'a ni que ni
tête
le ministre balaye les accusations
difficile de croire ce ministre des
Affaires étrangères qui pendant une
heure à nier devant nous l'existence du
trafic de cigarettes dans son pays avant
finalement de l'admettre à la fin de
l'interview parce qu'il croit la caméra
coupée
s'il y a du trafic de cigarettes au
Monténégro oui ma réponse est oui
vous savez ce n'est pas que nous mettons
de la mauvaise volonté
mais nous n'avons pas les moyens
matériels de lutter
des politiciens soupçonnés de corruption
à la tête d'un état une vraie mafia
impliquant des centaines de personnes il
y manquait le centre financier le
quartier général là où atterrissent les
millions de dollars du trafic avant
d'être réinvesti il est situé dans un
des lieux les plus paisible au monde à
30 km de la frontière avec l'Italie
ensuite à Lugano dans le canton du
Tessin un canton qui est depuis des
années dans le collimateur des juges
financiers de toute l'Europe pour sa
complaisance vis-à-vis de l'argent sale
ici par exemple viendrait se réfugier la
quasi-totalité de la fraude fiscale
italienne c'est dans cet immeuble costu
du quartier des affaires que Gérard
decommoy avait installé sa société
d'import-export la Maximus a à partir de
cette base le contrebandier présumé
passait commande de millions de
cigarettes auprès de grandes marques à
destination du Monténégro pour inonder
ensuite toute l'Europe
au dessin les trafiquants peuvent
trouver tous les banquiers et les
avocats dont ils ont besoin pour gérer
leurs affaires pour eux c'est aussi une
sorte d'asile en Suisse la loi
n'autorise pas l'extradition pour
contrebande de cigarettes
Adriano Corti l'ex associé de Gérard
decomo est un pur produit de la région
donc on est 200 000 habitants et puis
tous ceux qui habitent au sud c'est plus
ou moins ils sont tous au moins mêlés y
compris des ex à Jean de des agents de
police qui est vraiment il faisait les
sacs pour les cigarettes pour
transporter pour gagner quelque chose
sur leur salaire donc on se connaît tous
et puis on sait tous plus ou moins ce
qu'on fait
vous voulez dire que vous êtes tous un
peu contre mangués
nous on n'a jamais pensé que c'était de
la contrebande
tout le jeu c'est de cacher l'argent
pour confondre le réseau Komo le
procureur Chelsea de Barry a dû retracer
toutes les étapes d'un circuit financier
opaque éprouvé qu'il aboutit en fin de
course dans les comptes suisses de
gérardot Como
[Musique]
rive eldanar l'argent arrive par porteur
carrément dans des valises à double fond
de l'argent cash du liquide
bien aimé cet argent est introduit dans
les circuits bancaires à travers des
versements effectués par des financiers
et Queen ensuite il passe du circuit
bancaire au circuit commercial
nous avons retrouvé un des banquiers de
Gérard de promo il travaillait à la BNP
Paribas de Lugano avant d'en être
licencié il est poursuivi lui aussi dans
le procès de Barry pour association
mafieuse et recyclage d'argent sales au
téléphone il a accepté sous couvert
d'anonymats de nous expliquer la phase
ultime des opérations ce que la justice
italienne appelle le blanchiment
je lui faisais en fait des opérations
d'achat des ventes de devises monsieur
il encaissait
des échanges à terme
pour en fait
s'approvisionner de dollars pour faire
les paiements des factures
à travers cette série de passage
une perd la nature et la connaissance
profonde de la provenance illicite de
cet argent
parce qu'à cause justement de ces étapes
successives on a le plus grand mal à
faire la connexion entre l'argent
suspect et son origine
c'est manipulations d'argent gérardot
promo en connaît les rouages par cœur et
de longue date la consultation de son
casier judiciaire confirme que l'homme
est à contrebandier avéré depuis 30 ans
[Musique]
71 première condamnation pour
contrebande de cigarettes 20 jours de
détention
1974 condamnation pour contrebande des
cigarettes amandes 3 millions 200000
1982 arrestation pour contrebande de
cigarettes six mois de prison préventive
1983 condamnation pour trafic de
stupéfiant deux ans de prison
1986 condamnation à 50 réclusion et 40
millions de livres d'amende pour
contrebande de cigarettes
Gérard de Komo s'est retrouvé à 5
reprises face à la justice l'homme est
un contrebandier notoire son banquier
suisse lui a préféré fermer les yeux sur
ce genre de référence difficile de
refuser un client avec une telle surface
financière
[Musique]
un client qui était recherché par les
banques parce que on savait mais c'est
pas mon traité évidemment des sommes
très importantes tout le monde voulait
la voir en tant que client mais moi moi
j'étais convaincu comme tout le monde
chez nous donc BNP mais même sur
d'autres banques on était convaincu que
la marchandise était acheté et revendu
sur les gens de France ce qui veut dire
en fait que l'argent était tout à fait
légitime pour être retransférée les
fournisseurs de Girardot Komo les
multinationales du tabac elles n'ont
plus n'ont pas été très curieuse pendant
des années elles ont continué de lui
vendre des millions de cigarettes sans
apparemment se soucier de son curriculum
vitae de contrebandier
c'est un des éléments clés qui a
convaincu l'Union européenne d'attaquer
en justice les plus grands cigarettiers
mondiaux pour complicité de contrebande
l'accusation se fonde sur un document de
près de 200 pages dans lequel le cas
Gerardo como est en bonne place
la procédure a été ouverte au tribunal
de New York contre les fabricants
Philippe Maurice et Reynolds pour
contrebande et blanchiment d'argent
est l'un des conseillers juridiques de
l'Europe pour ses procès pour lui le
lien entre les fabricants et les
contrebandiers ne fait pas de doute
sont très claires ou on l'air très
clairs au tribunal et dans ce procès
de cigarettes savaient très bien ce qui
se passait et coopérer très étroitement
avec les trafiquants
[Musique]
de disproportionnées d'absurde voire
d'illégal pour se défendre les
cigarettiers déni toute relation avec
les contrebandiers ce n'est pas ce que
dit l'associé de Gérard de kouameau
Adriano Corti il était bien placé pour
en parler cou homo et lui-même traitait
bien avec Philippe Maurice
[Musique]
il y a des gros contrats qu'on pouvait
établir avec Philip Morris
payer les cigarettes par les banques
signalement les banques suisses et
c'était des contrats de 10 containers
par contrat qu'on pourrait renouveler
par semaine ou par mois en réalité pour
masquer les opérations avec Philip
Morris les contrebandiers ont eu recours
selon la justice à une astuce Un Phone
et
on a rencontré un ancien associé de Komo
nous a dit que comment il a acheté
directement à Philippe Maurice
satellite mais évidemment comme toutes
les sociétés satellites il y a jamais
donc le nom de la société officielle qui
circule je crois qu'il travaille avec
des sociétés
tout le monde même probablement pour les
papiers des taxes
selon la justice italienne les
transactions entre Gérard de Como et les
multinationales du tabac ont été
réalisés discrètement via une série de
sociétés écran placé dans des paradis
fiscaux exotiques
obamace hardwork Enterprise the moulin
Corporation aux îles vierge britanniques
nous avons demandé par fax à la
multinationale Philippe Morize de nous
expliquer la nature des relations
d'affaires qu'elle entretenait avec
gérardon et ce qu'elle savait de son
passé chargé de contrebandiers
la firme américaine n'a pas souhaité
nous répondre
fin mars le cigaretti américain a changé
de stratégie face aux attaques de
l'Union européenne devant la justice
américaine
l'affirma annoncé par communiqué de
presse qu'elle est en négociation avec
l'Union européenne pour un accord dans
la lutte contre le commerce illégal de
cigarette
la firme serait prête à verser 1
milliard de dollars sur 12 ans
officiellement pour financer la lutte
contre la contrebande en échange
l'Europe passerait l'éponge peut-être
une façon de ménager l'avenir en
arrêtant tout en quête sur leur liaison
dangereuses avec les trafiquants la
contrebande reste encore le moyen le
plus efficace de soutenir le marché de
la cigarette quand se multiplie les
campagnes anti-tabac
c'est destiné aux consommateurs que ce
soit dans du par contre bon ou que ce
soit vendu légalement voilà finalement
ça leur intéresse pas parce que de toute
façon eux ils vendent toujours la
cigarette au même prix la différence
c'est que le bénéfice c'est encaissé par
le contrebandier ou bien par l'État mais
ça ça ne regarde pas la vie des molles
sans produits vendus au même prix
[Musique]
la contrebande fait perdre chaque année
12 milliards d'euros au budget de
l'Europe communautaire à Barbès à Paris
au pied du métro les revendeurs volés au
successifs du prix du tabac comme une
aubaine pour leur commerce
en attendant l'arrivée massive comme en
Angleterre des grands réseaux
internationaux de contrebande et que le
trafic ne déborde des quartiers
spécialisés
[Musique]